dann wird das euch immer hammerfest auch
manchmal zu viel wie mails hier
telefonate da flexibel und dabei soll
will man immer präsent sein also
reagiert und sofort ab nachrichten
e-mails telefonanrufen und zwischendurch
versucht nun einfach weiter zu arbeiten
irgendwie durch kann hat nicht er ist
träger ein video
wie aber kommen wir durch diesen
kommunikations dschungel
ich hätte da ein paar tipps für euch
legt fest was ihr wann machen wollt also
wann wir welche aufgabe erledigt und wie
viel zeit wir dafür einplanen wollt so
könnt ihr euch besser auf eine sache
konzentrieren
unterbrechungen können richtige
produktivitäts keller sei und
versuchungen haben ergeben dass es
durchschnittlich bis zu 23 minuten
dauert bis man wieder in ein thema
beendet nachdem man unterbrochen wurde
was nicht gleich zwei dem nächsten punkt
führt setzt prioritäten wenn ihr
kontaktiert werdet überlegt euch muss
ich jetzt sofort antworten oder hat es
noch fall wenn jemand unsere hilfe
braucht dann sollten wir diese leisten
allerdings oder brechen wir dabei unsere
eigene tätigkeit und das könnte wiederum
den fortschritt des gesamten teams
beeinträchtigen das also immer abwägen
natürlich gibt es auch dringende
angelegenheiten die sofort geklärt
werden durch die regatten video aber ich
rufe dich in einer stunde zurück
aber wenn nicht verschiebt es und
konzentriert euch auf eure aktuelle
aufgabe
[Musik]
versuch die kommunikation euren
bedürfnissen anzupassen
womit fühlt ihr euch müller sprechen
oder schreiben ich weiß natürlich kann
man sich das nicht immer aussuchen
heute ist die kamera china wo ich schon
einige faszinierende aufsätze darüber
gelesen wie viel schwieriger diese
kommunikations tools für frauen sind als
für männer
zb wegen der beleuchtung und wie das
medium einen selbst wieder gibt viele
von uns kommuniziert lieber in textform
darum könnten wir verabreden dinge über
e-mail oder slack abzuklären
andere wiederum greifen lieber zum
telefonhörer und das nimmt sofort die
anspannung vor einer video besprechen
hier verbringen täglich zwei bis drei
stunden damit unsere mails zu checken
wäre doch toll wenn wir das reduzieren
könnten macht pausen wie oft haben wir
das schon gehört macht pausen aber
ernsthaft macht pausen
[Musik]
das ist wichtig für eure gesundheit in
ihrer produktivität genauso wie ein
ungestörter feierabend
[Musik]